cette info ou intox avec vous je me
shoote au bonjour bonjour affaires le
mois de juin c'est celui des fiertés des
événements sont organisés aux quatre
coins du monde pour faire reconnaître et
célébrer la communauté lgbt plus c'est
dans ce contexte surgissent d'étranges
drapeau arc en ciel voilà déjà on va
commencer par le plus classique vous le
connaissez sans doute il s'agit du
drapeau arc-en-ciel ans il a vu le jour
en
1979 créé par l'artiste militant
américain gilbert baker donc vous voyez
un derrière moi si band 6 couleur qui
symbolise par exemple la vie la guérison
le soleil la sérénité ou encore l'esprit
et aujourd'hui encore c'est le symbole
le plus répandu à travers le monde
notamment brandi vous l'avait dit lors
du mois des fiertés ans au mois de juin
le mois des fiertés de la communauté
lgbt sont que des drapeaux mais d'autres
variantes se sont ajoutés depuis 2010
8,1 et entre autres voilà parce qu'en
fait certains militants trouvé que ce
drapeau que six couleurs ce n'était pas
assez 1 qu'il fallait rendre le drapeau
encore plus inclusive en 2020 clusif en
2018 l'artiste daniel cassard ya donc
ajouter des couleurs sur la gauche qui
représentent d'autres minorités comme
les personnes de couleur les personnes
transsexuelles ou séropositives et la
flèche qui pointent donc vers la droite
symbolise le côté progressiste du
mouvement voilà donc pour la variante
2018 et certains internautes parlent
maintenant d'une autre variante la
version 2022 alors la voici quelles
différences et les couleurs jaune et
bleu en fait en étaient à ajouter vous
le voyez dans le dans le triangle juste
à l'extrême du triangle et ce sont les
couleurs du drapeau ukrainien ce drapeau
commence à être ridicule on nous dit par
exemple ce cet internaute qui trouve qu'
il y a trop de couleurs celui ci nous
dit pourquoi on ajoute encore des bandas
ce truc ou encore c'est ça et même été
repris par des sources plus officielle
par exemple cet élu au sénat réputé
c'était lui républicaine au sénat
américain marjorie taylor green qui se
demandent est ce que les nazis en ciel
qui le dit dans l'armée ukrainienne sont
au courant de ce drapeau un sous-entendu
l'armée ukrainienne serait homophobes et
c'est bon alors il faut quand même dire
que cette femme cet élu est très connu
pour protéger pour propager des faits
qui news tendance extrême droite alors
cette fois-ci s'agit-il d'une flic news
julie et bien oui raphaël 1 puisque en
fait à la base il s'agit d'une blague
tout simplement de la pure ironie en
fait tout est parti de ce tweet qui
incite à utiliser justement la version
plus inclusif du drapeau arc-en-ciel
celle de 2018 que je vous ai montré donc
voilà c'est ce que dit ce conte
militants et en réponse à cet internaute
l'a clairement pour se moquer de cette
inclusion à outrance répond je cite je
tiens à préciser que ces couleurs
n'inclut pas certaines personnes par
exemple les ukrainiens voici donc le
drapeau 2020 deux mises à jour avec les
couleurs inclusive mais c'était une
blague tout simplement pour se moquer du
drapeau 2018 et c'est donc là que ce
faux drapeau 2022 est apparu c'était
donc pour rire et ceux qui le prennent
au premier degré et d'un fond totalement
fausse route autre symbole de la
communauté lgbt plus la lie quand vous
la verrez d'ailleurs peut-être sur
certains traits y de soldats ukrainien
et ça ce n'est pas une fait qu'il nous
un raphaël puisque certains combattants
et combattantes de l'armée ukrainienne
ont réellement cousu un écusson licorne
sur l'entrée vous l'avez dit cet animal
mythique 1 c'est un symbole de la
communauté lgbt plus est dans l'armée et
craignent elles en fait certains
l'arborent pour assumer en fait aux yeux
de tous leur sexualité justement pour la
revendiquer une pratique qui est apparue
en 2014 lors de l'annexion de la crimée
par la russie et à cette époque en fait
il était courant de dire que dans
l'armée clignet rieder n'y avait pas
d'homosexuels
c'est complètement faux confirme les
soldats donc qui sont interrogés dans
cet article de nos confrères de reuters
et qui arbore justement ce cet écusson
en forme de licorne voilà ils en sont la
preuve vivante en des membres de la
communauté lgbt
plus ukrainienne eux aussi risquent leur
vie sur le front et voilà pourquoi il
abhorre la licorne sur leur tri et pour
terminer sur ce mois des fiertés
direction à présent julie l'arabie
saoudite alors un royaume a pas
franchement connu pour sa tolérance
envers les minorités sexuelles et selon
cette publication viral sur instagram
l'arabie saoudite organiserait même en
juin un mois de la fierté hétérosexuelle
alors l'opposé de ce qui se passe
ailleurs la publication reprend
l'habillage de bbc1 la chaîne anglaise
mais attention si l'on regarde de plus
près on voit déjà des petites
différences avec le logo officiel
l'image est donc un mental un montage et
comme le rappelle le site full fact de
faux tweets de la bbc surgissent 20
apparaissent vraiment régulièrement sur
internet est un réflexe à avoir sachez
le la bbc partage presque toujours un
lien vers un de ses articles dans ses
tweets là ce n'est pas le cas et pour
cause il est complètement bidon un sweat
l'arabie saudite n'organise pas du tout
de moi de l'hétérosexualité et là encore
ce tweet provient surtout de compte
parodique et là encore c'est un trait
d'humour qui était pris au premier degré
merci julie c'était info ou intox avec
julie chouteau